today readers across the world are
getting their first real look at Harper
Lee's go set a watchman I say real look
because the first chapter was published
in a newspaper a few days ago this of
course is the follow-up novel to the 55
year old classic to kill a mockingbird
this new book is one of the few surprise
sequels which barnes and noble says will
help boost its sales by a full
percentage point this year if realized
that would bark the company is best
improvement in at least seven years
Bloomberg's Raymond asensio has been
looking at the astounding numbers around
this well To Kill a Mockingbird the
classic and this follow-up I set a
watchman right there someone with us
sure this sequel basically their first
off so many superlatives I could just
keep on going on this but first we'll
talk about the numbers an initial print
run of 2 million books that's already a
lot in an absolute way but put that in
perspective its first print run is
actually two thirds larger than the
final hunger games book which we know
was already a very well received and
more than twice that of the last game of
thrones installment now earlier we spoke
to an analyst Barry Lucas at gabelli &
Company and he says that this could
actually translate into 30 million
dollars for News Corp which is the
parent company of HarperCollins our own
Bloomberg reporting though said that
could push as close to 40 million
dollars once this whole entire run if it
gets sold out and it looks like it will
does get sold out there for comparison
the divergent series I don't know if you
guys watch watch the movies for that but
it's of course it's supposed to buckle
in thickness Chicago and similar to
hunger games or something that book that
series helps News Corp News Corp's book
publishing division by 83% 253 million
dollars and one in one quarter alone so
this could be a very big boon for news
corp it this goes ahead books and
obviously general Mockingbird is still a
big seller itself yeah exactly uh
basically of course it has 55 years on
to side of Watchmen but it has given
royalties to Harper Lee the author of
nine thousand dollars per day she hasn't
had to work because of this continuously
even to this day she's 89 years old
she's retired and
is living in a nursing home thank
goodness she doesn't have to work no she
doesn't is that was impressing at 89
years old still having to go to a job
every day well she's a one-hit wonder at
least up until it for this time and
that's all she needed but in the first
half of 2009 for example she raked in
1.7 million all told she earns about 3.2
million dollars in royalties each and
every single year so she totally has
been set and if you happen to be lucky
enough to get a single first edition
copy of tequila Mockingbird you can get
twenty thousand dollars for that so ah
collector's item so many numbers out
there so many superlatives all right
it's really it's a really cool story
it's really fascinating actually the
whole backstory and I recommend to
viewers if you didn't see it on business
week on our cover go back and definitely
read that because there's so many
questions about why this came out should
it come out and an interesting plot
twist to yes we have Atticus Finch being
the lawyer who protects African
Americans and then the Dunton I won't
spoil it very good point all right don't
no spoilers streaming assess yeah thanks
very much for that